>>> A U.S. ARMY REVIEW OF THE
CHAOTIC U.S. EXIT FROM
AFGHANTAN WAS OBTAINED BY THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
THE COMMANDER REPORTED THE
MILITARY WOULD HAVE BEEN, QUOTE,
MUCH BETTER PREPARED TO CONDUCT
A MORE ORDERLY EVACUATION IF
POLICYMAKERS HAD PAID ATTENTION
TO THE INDICATORS OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND,
UNQUOTE.
A FEW DAYS AGO, NBC NEWS ASKED
PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT THE
ACCOUNTS IN THESE DOCUMENTS.
>> INTERVIEWED MANY MILITARY
OFFICIALS AND OFFICERS WHO SAID
THE ADMINISTRATION IGNORED THE
HANDWRITING ON THE WALL.
ANOTHER DESCRIBED TRYING TO GET
FOLKS IN THE EMBASSY READY TO
EVACUATE, ENCOUNTERING PEOPLE
WHO WERE ESSENTIALLY IN DENIAL
OF THE SITUATION.
DOES ANY OF THAT RING TRUE TO
YOU?
>> NO.
NO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS TOLD.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS TOLD,
THE PRESIDENT SAID.
NOT WHAT HE WAS TOLD.
THE DOCUMENTS GO INTO DETAIL
ABOUT HOW IN THE VIEWS OF THE
SERVICE MEMBERS ON THE GROUND,
THE U.S. AMBASSADOR AND OTHERS
IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DID
NOT SEE THE SECURITY THREAT FOR
WHAT IT REALLY WAS AND DID NOT
ADEQUATELY PREPARE FOR
WITHDRAWAL, THAT THERE WAS A
LACK OF URGENCY.
THE DAY KABUL FELL TO THE
TALIBAN, THEY WERE GOING ROOM TO
ROOM PUSHING STATE DEPARTMENT TO
RESPOND AND SOME WERE, QUOTE,
INCOX TATED AND COWERING IN
ROOMS.
AND OTHERS OPERATING LIKE IT WAS
DAY-TO-DAY OPERATIONS AND
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE OF URGENCY
OR RECOGNITION IN THE SITUATION.
THE SAME ATTITUDE SEEN IN A
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL,
QUOTE, WERE THERE ANY TRUTH TO
IT, WE PRESUMABLY WOULD NOT BE
LEARNING OF IT SIX MONTHS AFTER
THE FACT, UNQUOTE.
YET, THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
BAD INFORMATION NOT FLOWING
UPWARD, THAT'S A LONG-STANDING
TRADITION.
ALMOST TEN YEARS AGO, AS THEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN PREPARED TO
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN, I ASKED HIM
THIS QUESTION SUGGESTED BY A
SOLDIER FRIEND.
>> DO YOU FEEL THE REPORTING YOU
RECEIVED FROM THE PENTAGON FULLY
REPRESENTS WHAT THE ON GROUND
COMMANDERS ASSESS, IS THERE ANY
DISCONNECT BETWEEN WHAT LEADERS
FEEL THE PUBLIC AND PRESIDENT
WANT TO HEAR VERSUS WHAT IS
OCCURRING ON THE GROUND?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I EMPHASIZE
WHENEVER I'M TALKING TO JOHN
ALLEN OR THE JOINT CHIEFS OR ANY
OF THE OFFICERS WHO ARE IN
AFGHANISTAN IS, I CAN'T AFFORD A
WHITEWASH.
I CAN'T AFFORD NOT GETTING THE
VERY BEST INFORMATION IN ORDER
TO MAKE GOOD DECISIONS.
I THINK THE REPORTS WE GET ARE
RELATIVELY ACCURATE IN THE SENSE
THAT THERE IS REAL IMPROVEMENT.
>> WE KNOW NOW THE DEGREE TO
WHICH SO MANY OF THESE REPORTS
WERE WHITEWASHES, SO OPTIMISTIC
AS TO HAVE BEEN FALSE.
THE THING IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
KNEW THIS THEN.
BIDEN HAS BEEN A SKEPTIC OF
THE 1/2 IN AFGHANISTAN FOR
YEARS, PRECISELY BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T BUY INTO THE ROSIE
SCENARIOS FROM FOGGY BOTTOM AND
FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> ARE YOU REJECTING THE
CONCLUSIONS OR THE ACCOUNTS THAT
ARE IN THIS ARMY REPORT?
>> YES, I AM.
>> SO THEY'RE NOT TRUE?
>> I'M REJECTING THEM.
>> IT'S DIFFICULT TO OVERSTATE
HOW INSULTING IT IS, GIVEN THE
FULL CONTENT OF THE 2,000 PAGES
OF DOCUMENTS IN THIS U.S. ARMY
INVESTIGATION WHICH CNN HAS ALSO
OBTAINED.
MANY ACCOUNTS WERE FROM TROOPS
ON THE GROUND AT THE GATES NEAR
THE CANAL AROUND THE AIRPORT,
NON-COMMISSIONED OFFICERS,
JUNIOR OFFICERS, JOES, PEOPLE
WITH LITTLE POLITICAL MOTIVATION
TO LIE AND HEAVY LEGAL AND MORAL
OBLIGATION TO TELL THE TRUTH IN
SWORN STATEMENTS.
PEOPLE LIKE THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT BIDEN VISITED WITH LAST
NOVEMBER AT FT. BRAGG.
>> WHAT'S AMAZING TO ME IS HOW
PROUD I AM TO BE YOUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
YOU ARE THE MOST INCREDIBLE
GROUP OF WOMEN AND MEN, WARRIORS
THAT WE'VE EVER SEEN.
>> PEOPLE IN THAT NORTH CAROLINA
CROWD SERVED WITH STAFF SERGEANT
RYAN KNAUS, A SPECIAL OPERATIONS
SOLDIER STATIONED TESTIMONIES
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ARE A BIG
PART OF THE REPORT AND ONE OF
HIS FINAL MOMENTS, HE WAS ONE OF
13 AMERICAN SERVICE MEMBERS
KILLED DURING THE ABBEY GATE
SUICIDE BOMBING IN AUGUST.
THOUGH THE NAME AND RANK ARE
REDACTED FROM THE RECORD IT'S
CLEAR THE SERVICE MEMBER GIVING
THE TESTIMONY KNEW THE STAFF
SERGEANT.
HE DESCRIBES THE CHAOS AT THE
SCENE, THE CROWDS OF AFGHANS
PUSHING AND SHOVING THEIR WAY
INTO ABBEY GATE.
HE TELLS OF BEING KNOCKED TO THE
GROUND BY THE EXPLOSION OF THE
SUICIDE BOMBER, GETTING UP AND
DRAGGING HIS UNCONSCIOUS BUT
STILL BREATHING TEAMMATE AWAY
FROM FURTHER DANGER, TRYING TO
KEEP HIM FROM CHOKING ON HIS
SWOLLEN TONGUE.
HE LOADS HIM INTO THE BED OF THE
TRUCK, CLEARS HIS WEAPON AND
TUCKS IT BESIDE HIS TEAMMATE AND
THE TRUCK DRIVES AWAY.
>> YOU DO SO MUCH AND YOUR
FAMILIES GIVE SO MUCH.
I REALLY MEAN IT.
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
AND SO I JUST -- WE CAME BECAUSE
WE WANTED TO THANK YOU, TELL YOU
HOW MUCH WE CARE.
>> I DON'T DOUBT PRESIDENT BIDEN
CARES, BUT I DO NOT UNDERSTAND
WHY HE WOULD NOT MANIFEST THAT
CARE INTO TAKING THIS
INVESTIGATION MORE SERIOUSLY,
ABSORBING THE TRAGIC DETAILS,
CONTEMPLATING THE OBVIOUS
FAILURES OF HIS ADMINISTRATION.
FAILURES THAT COST LIVES.
BIDEN ALWAYS BRISTLES AT THIS
BECAUSE HE FEELS CONFIDENT THAT
ENDING THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN
WAS THE RIGHT DECISION, BUT
THAT'S NOT THE QUESTION AT HAND.
IT'S NOT WEATHER, BUT HOW THE
WAR ENDED.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE WHEN IT
DID FINALLY END.
NO PART OF THESE MILITARY
INTERVIEWS RING TRUE BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS TOLD?
IF THIS WAS NOT WHAT YOU WERE
TOLD, THEN WHAT WAS?
AND DON'T YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION, SIR, TO BE TOLD?
DON'T YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
RYAN'S FAMILY, TO HIS GRIEVING
MOTHER?
>> THEY WERE SITTING DUCKS.
HOW DO I FEEL?
I FEEL GRIEF AND I FEEL ANGER.
I AM ANGRY FOR T